lo primero que hay que decir es que
cuatro años y medio después del
referendo en el que se votó
mayoritariamente para que el reino
unido- saliera de la unión europea se ha
logrado este acuerdo en la nueva
relación empezará el primero de enero de
2021 hace pocos minutos terminó en
downing street en el centro de londres
la conferencia de prensa del primer
ministro que arrancó con un tono
victorioso diciendo que el reino unido
ha recuperado entonces su soberanía en
aguas en fronteras y en su presupuesto
como ustedes mencionaban es un acuerdo
de que se ha dado detalles especialmente
a nivel comercial
boris johnson ha dicho que se accede a
este gran mercado de la unión europea
pero no habría tarifas sin embargo
después el mismo dijo que sobre todo en
derechos pesqueros que ha sido una de
las grandes dificultades en los últimos
meses en este en negociación es que
habrá un período de transición de cinco
años y medio para algunos para los
expertos esto ya es una tarifa así que
habrá mucho más
analizar a lo largo de los meses
siguientes en fishing en los derechos
pesqueros dice boris johnson que el
acuerdo ha sido bueno para toda europa
que el reino unido tiene también los
mismos intereses de la unión europea ha
dicho además que a partir de este
momento del reino unido empezará a
buscar lograr otros acuerdos comerciales
por ejemplo con eeuu porque ya no
estando el unión europea puede tener
este tipo de independencia y cada parte
del país se beneficiará con este acuerdo
haciendo un guiño directo a escocia e
irlanda del norte que son gran parte de
los afectados he dicho que el parlamento
británico será convocado el próximo 30
de diciembre un día antes de que termine
este periodo de transición para que el
acuerdo sea ratificado en el palacio de
westminster